yeah so women who code we serve uh 290
000 members around the world and uh
before the pandemic hit we were almost
entirely in person and so we were
serving members in 20 countries today
we're serving members in 134
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders it's not
every day that i get to speak to
somebody who's making an impact on
hundreds of thousands of people around
the world meet elena percival ceo and
co-founder of women who code under
elena's leadership the organization has
grown to serve 290 000 members in 134
countries helena is an accomplished tech
speaker appearing at wall street journal
dot d live code motion milan grace
hopper columbia university social
enterprise and more
elena has been published by forbes
huffington post on the wall street
journal she holds a master's in
organizational management and an mba she
is also an angel investor a venture
partner at valor ventures serves on the
board of atl family meal and is the
codepath advisor
elena percival thank you so much for
joining me on 20 minute leaders welcome
to my show how are you
i'm doing great thank you for having me
thank you so much for joining me i know
how busy and i really appreciate it
you've done incredible things and and i
can't wait to pick your brain in these
20 minutes
about about your work in the tech
ecosystem but more importantly your work
with with women who code and
the scale that you reached which i'll
let you describe it in a second because
the numbers are just ginormous and if i
say them nobody will believe me
it's it's an incredible impact and
and so i'm excited to hear both you know
why you're choosing to spend so much
time on it and sort of the
entrepreneurial process because you're
also in venture capital and in your
full-time position so tell me a little
bit about you know your you know your
upbringing and your entrance into the
tech world and what brings you to create
and now be and i'll be the ceo of women
who code yeah so i took a roundabout way
to the tech industry i um started off my
career in traditional business i ended
up moving um to germany right out of
college with a congressional scholarship
and so i spent one year there and was
able to get a job at puma the shoe
company and so i worked there
in germany for
uh three years in their global
headquarters and then i wanted to go
back and back to school and do an mba i
wasn't quite ready to
you know return to the united states so
i found this amazing program that was a
dual degree program where you'd study in
the united states and you'd study um
and paris as well and do your company
visits in uh in uh china and
you had a segment that was in brazil
and so i i was committed to this kind of
global approach
and i i did that and
finished my degree at uh during 08
right when the market was crashing and
so one of the extremely lucky ones who
was able to
find a job at that time
coming out of out of school and i found
a job with a really small women's
performance footwear company so i'm
still in traditional industry but it's a
tiny company and they brought me on to
help launch the first women's specific
volleyball and basketball shoe so i'm
getting into that women's empowerment
space in a professional manner i think
that was always something that was
personally important to me
but
i um was in this teeny tiny company and
with nike and mizuno immediately being
our biggest competitors i had to learn
differently and that was as
technology and social media was emerging
and so that i started to pull on and it
really felt to me like
working at a at a startup um so shortly
after that
i had the opportunity to move to the bay
area and that's one of those places that
you know if you get the chance just do
it and so i did and i i had this amazing
career
and i was stalling out in in san
francisco because i wasn't coming from
facebook i wasn't coming from the tech
industry i wasn't coming from you know
google or any of the top tech
organizations and i needed to translate
my skills so i started learning to code
i
built side projects i built um you know
just cool programs that i personally was
using
and i sort of found my way
to
the tech industry in a community aspect
and just found that you know my
organizational back uh management
background and community building
background led really well to women who
code as it was um
just emerging it was kind of starting
off as the small
just
amazing community in san francisco where
you know we were supporting each other
we were having a great time we were
making friends
and then the world started talking about
teaching girls to code and teaching
women to code
and we were in the industry and one of
the huge barriers was constantly needing
to prove actually that you were at just
the level that you were at not even
proving that your potential could be so
much more and so this amazing
conversation of teaching girls to code
teaching women to code
without elevating the woman in the
industry
is a threat to her
and so we said hey we need to tell our
story as well and i realized at that
point in time that supporting women who
excel in the industry was just as
important as getting women in the
industry and getting girls to pursue
um
so that's where the nonprofit uh the
idea around it kind of uh came together
in the mission and the vision of of
seeing a world where you know women are
better represented as technologists and
leaders
so you know at the end most non-profits
that they have an impact but the impact
doesn't nearly reach the scale that that
you've had
walk me through the point where you're
at where you're deciding okay i'm gonna
this is a mission this is something that
needs to be and it needs to be in a
global level how are you strategically
thinking about approaching this problem
you know even you know and understanding
a question of scale because you
understand that the ecosystem you under
you with a business school you
understand you know the different
challenges what's your thinking through
yeah um
in in thinking through this um
you know at first it was just a passion
project and then i realized it was
important and then i realized how much
impact we're having so it wasn't
building out a traditional business
model and and growing it uh it was
hitting
the right thing at the right time when
the market needed it and doing something
that i absolutely loved so i was able to
put that 120 percent in or you know 200
percent and when um as you're building
it and growing it and
you know
being very
volunteer driven has enabled us to be on
the ground in communities all over the
world so that we're able to adapt to the
needs of the local market and
and that has really enabled us to grow
very quickly
right and so women code what what is
your thesis as to
helping women advance in the tech
ecosystem on the on the engineering side
of things
so
what my thinking is is every industry is
becoming a technology industry and right
now over the past few years you've heard
reports like there's more
men named john who are running you know
some of the top um
uh businesses public companies in the
world than there are women and so
when i think hey what what are future
business leaders skill sets going to be
it's going to involve technology and
your
like security is going to be as
important as finance and your skill set
and so if we don't see women represented
and leveling up in the tech industry in
technical roles
we're going to fall even further behind
that that leadership pipeline and so
that to me is is really the crux of it
from a personal standpoint yes uh the
tech industry is the fastest growing
industry yes um we the market uh
you know the people that we have to
perform the roles aren't meeting the
market needs so there's tremendous
career opportunity there um yes uh if
you look at top jobs to have at least
three or four of them in the top 10 are
in you know the technology space
but even more so looking ahead if women
aren't filling those roles if they
aren't um leveling up and staying
engaged in that that technical and
leadership career path
um
you know the the future will have uh
less of a chance of having women
represented at the leadership levels
and and over the years what have you
found successful in in you know
creating this massive community and tell
me you know even before this question
tell me a little bit about the
the scope of what's happening today with
women who code in terms of a little bit
of numbers and geographies
yeah so women who code we serve uh 290
000 members around the world
and
before the pandemic hit we were almost
entirely in person and so we are serving
members in 20 countries today we're
serving members in 134
wow holy crap
the day the cobot happened what what's
your thinking you have to you have to
move hundreds of thousands of people
literally from being from being ready to
engage in person to now having to be
ready to engage online and we're talking
about a community here this is not a
traditional work environment
yeah we heard loud and clear from our
community as we were being told to
isolate that they still wanted a way to
connect and so we saw amazing ways not
just
going digital so making it possible so
if you don't happen to be in a major
tech hub like you know new york or san
francisco or tel aviv that you have that
opportunity to still
connect and
have resources for developing your
career um but you know that that moment
hit and we said you know we we have to
do everything differently our community
still needs us it's time for us to lean
in and so
we actually sped up our kind of digital
transformation but by probably three to
five years and
we're of course all looking forward to
the opportunity to be able to
uh return back but we know that digital
element is going to stay a very very
strong part of our organization
right and so what did you lose and what
did you gain by moving
to digital
yeah so we lost the opportunity to to
see face to face to meet people in your
your local community um that you might
be able to bond with and and become uh
you know close friends um but we've
moved it into the digital space and so
now
if you're a single mom and don't have
your evenings free you can still have
access to our events online if you
happen to be um in a
a smaller town um where women who could
wasn't having events you have access to
um to our our programming and then
further because it is all digital now
we're recording everything so our
youtube channel has exploded over the
past year and you have all of this rich
on-demand content that you can watch you
know the whole hour you can watch you
know in five-minute segments you can
revisit uh things that were especially
interesting to you and so while we're
serving this community um it's just
opened us up to anybody who who needs
access to it when they need access to it
so if as the ceo you had to draw some
some red lines or things that are so
critical to your mission and to to the
work
did any of those get you know get
damaged in it through through moving to
the to digitalization in other words i
understand that there are different
drawbacks to what happened and moving
digitally i'm trying to also understand
are there some really critical things
that that we've lost
or or are there just more things that we
gained
yeah
um i i mean
i would say that last year
the entire year felt like kind of
adapting in a place of fear we had no
idea
what was coming how long it would last
um we saw all of our sponsorships dry up
in a month and this is how we're able to
provide our programming for free um so
coming into this year and seeing that
hey actually
a lot of tech companies had some other
best years ever um
and and moving forward and seeing hey we
can do something entirely different and
actually just unlock people's minds to
be able to say
we don't have to do things the way we
did and that's something that women who
code has been
pushing forward since the beginning is
just because the rules were set this way
by some group of specific people over
you know the past
50 or hundreds of years we can think
outside the box and
forced radical
uh transformation enables you know you
to be able to think i can do it entirely
differently and so i'm
very excited um about the possibilities
that have come out of um this
this forced um time of of transformation
um but we have to be
thinking that way we have to be thinking
how can it be
better otherwise we're just going to
repeat
the same mistakes the we're just going
to pull forward um what is ready to be
shed
right 100 and so for people that are
interested in in in either non-profits
or working on any projects that are
non-trivial and make an impact what did
you learn over the last nine years or so
that you know would be that are
non-trivial that would be beneficial for
young entrepreneurs that want to come in
and have that that dramatic impact and
reach anything close to the scale that
you've reached
yeah so i would say um young
entrepreneurs out there
if you want to do a mission-driven
company make it a mission-driven
for-profit there's not a reason that it
has to be a non-profit
um
from our our type of organization we
don't get support because
people are you know donating we get
support because of the the services that
we're bringing and providing
to companies in our community and
you can build something that that you
own that you can
have invested in that you can um you
know stand
on the stage of the new york stock
exchange and and ring the bell because
you're you've brought your company um
public and so i i would say there's
my learnings from from running a
non-profit is it doesn't have to be a
non-profit you can create amazing change
in the world you can bring a mission
forward and it can be something that
is building you know personal wealth for
you as well
so what's next what's the vision
um our
the the next thing that i really want to
be tackling with women who code is um
closing the leadership gap at the first
rung and the main reason that this
really needs focus is because women are
judged on their experience and men are
judged on their uh potential uh just as
a kind of a societal move and so what we
want to do is make sure that we are
building practice-based leadership
opportunities for women to make them
promotion ready to really make them com
competitive and
there's 50 000 um
you know entry level leadership
roles opening up in the tech industry
over the next five years if women could
represent 50 of those we can actually
shift the percentage of women in
leadership by about 30 percent
and while doing that in five years is is
mind-blowing
unbelievable elena thank you so much for
taking time to share with me i want to
take you back for for a few minutes to
to your personal you know journey and
your childhood specifically what really
fascinated you growing up
what really drove your curiosity
oh um i've always been an adventurer and
um someone who likes to try new things
so i i get involved i get excited about
something and i want to move on for it
from it pretty quickly so um we were
talking um at my company about
a favorite memory and
um a favorite childhood memory for me
was a road trip that i i just took a
solo road trip with my mom i was the
navigator um we went all the way from
atlanta georgia up to maine which um
is a multi-day trip
even if you're driving for you know six
to eight hours per day and it was just
an incredible adventure and i think i've
carried that forward i i've been to
about 75 countries uh now that i've
been
an adult and i've
lived in in several of them and
um
yeah i i think that global focus and
that global approach is something that's
just really uh core to me and you have
to think hey uh i i'm not gonna be you
know san francisco-centric or u.s
centric or
whatever it is you you have to continue
to um build your team to
to have um
the
the values um that you want instilled in
your company
and if you were to look at the different
things that you're doing today
and your day by day and
what what are some things that really
inspire you
in in everything that you do
yeah um
oh
i feel like my role shifts uh from from
day to day um but having the the
opportunity to really dig deep with our
team and make sure that inclusion is at
the core both internally and externally
that's a process um that we have been
focusing on ourselves and bringing in
external experts to hold us accountable
and help um continue to push us forward
for the past couple of years um
i
love the opportunity to interact with
our volunteers and learn about how it
impacts
their careers some of the
really amazing things that
i hear is you know our mexico city
director
within one year her salary increased by
200 percent we had um one of our
directors in atlanta georgia and when
she first started she was you know
masters in cs but incredibly shy she
stood at the front of the room became a
leader
and within one year she was invited to
give tech talks to standing room only
crowds wow unbelievable thank you so
much for sharing all these all this
amazing with stories with me i think
it's just incredible and three words
that you would use to describe yourself
ah um uh grit
um
optimistic and
passionate
i love it elena thank you so much this
was great hey thank you for the great
work that you're doing i think it's very
inspiring and stay safe and stay healthy
thank you thank you very much have a you
as well
thank you
you